of course there's also this topic of  visibility in a nutshell think about try  to put yourself into the shoes of a  partner maybe every half a year there's  then the evaluation season in that  partner needs to decide what associate  gets what ranking what performance  ranking which determines your bonus  which also determines the speed of your  promotions wait who is more likely to  get their promotion if the different  Associates got very similar evaluations  for instance from the Project Lead is it  the person who this partner vividly  remembers from regular team interaction  steam dinners or is the person that in  all these interactions just sat there  didn't contribute much didn't do  anything to just somehow be remembered  really by the partner in a significant  way well I hope it's not surprising to  anyone that very likely it's the former  person who has the advantage